bons amis bonjour merci d'être avec nous
par téléphone ce matin sur rtl france
pour parler de la cour internationale de
justice on disait qui va trancher sur
les différends entre les états entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan qui rend
aujourd'hui ces ordonnances les deux
pays qui s'accusent mutuellement de
discrimination raciale qu'est-ce qui va
se jouer très concrètement aujourd'hui à
la haye
et surtout un enjeu très symbolique
puisque comme vous l'avez vous même la
cour n'a pas les moyens de contraindre
et de faire respecter les décisions
qu'elle prend pas et donc il s'agira
quand même d'une diffusion avant un
bolide et psychologique et ce qui est en
fait le plus important de la rencontre
récente il y a eu entre les dirigeants
de l'arménie et de l'azerbaïdjan
ils se sont rencontrés récemment en
russie sous le patronage russe et une
rencontre des frères art les dirigeants
des deux pays ennemis et staff est un
événement beaucoup plus fondamentale
alors chacun s'accuse de discrimination
est ce qu'on sait précisément sur quoi
sa porte
oui oui il y à toute une série
d'accusations mutuelles l'air hip hop
ils sont sans doute exact des deux côtés
les deux pays se détestent et un peu en
effet des discriminations sont lieu des
deux côtés
l'azerbaïdjan accuse également l'arménie
d'avoir posé des champs de mines et on
peut penser que
certes les discriminations sont
réciproques mais il ne faut pas oublier
que dans la sphère du haut karabakh à
l'azerbaïdjan qui a été l'agresseur est
ce que dans certaines zones il tient là
conclut sur les arméniens l'azerbaïdjan
se livrer à une véritable politique de
purification
et nice est aussi culturel avec des
saccages dans le patrimoine christian et
arméniens donc d l'élimination des deux
côtés mais
est condamnable des deux côtés mais
vraisemblablement bien plus forte du
côté de l'agresseur et l'azerbaïdjan
alors dans ce contexte justement des
députés européens pointent le manque
d'action de bruxelles qu'est ce qu'il
reproche à l'europe aujourd'hui
oui tout à fait l'europe est
complètement papules d'or crise est en
fait les deux vrais du temps et ont géré
la crise au détriment non seulement de
l'europe de même les occidentaux de
manière donald et la turquie le red
state erdogan est le parrain de
l'azerbaïdjan avec l'azerbaïdjan a été
armée par deux pays la turquie et israël
et d'autre part il y à la russie de la
lune y est le parrain de l'arménie est
maintenant
assurent la sécurité de l'arménie ce
sont ces deux pays et d'allemands sont à
la fois rivaux mais d'accord entre eux
pour
illuminer les occidentaux de la région
et du règlement du conflit justement
elle la russie qui maintient la paix sur
le terrain combien de temps ça peut
durer est ce que finalement ce n'est pas
une entente artificiel
je pense que ça peut durer là assez
longtemps par que la puissance militaire
russe des redoutables savait que là au
moment du conflit la russie avait
provisoirement lâché d'harmonie pour
deux raisons d'une part parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas d'accord de détendre la
russie et le haut karabakh il ya un
accord avec l'harmonie pour protéger le
territoire arménien a lui-même on ne
s'attendait pas au karabakh et d'autre
part des autorités arméniennes avaient
mené une politique rester hantés russe
de distanciation vis-à-vis de la russie
et de rapprochement vis-à-vis des
occidentaux est donc dans un premier
temps la russie avait testé d arménia
débrouiller seul en leur disant vous
vers elias tantôt font quelque chose
pour nous pas et ensuite une fois que
l'arménie à dix ont été
punis par les revers badge ans avec
lequel
la lumière ne veut pas se cacher non
plus la russie est intervenue pour
mettre fin au conflit ont gelé les
choses et elle a déployé une sur place
une force militaire assez important et
étant donné les capacités militaires de
la russie fait quelque chose il a peut
durer un moment merci beaucoup jean loup
bellamy d'avoir accepté notre invitation
je le rappelle vous êtes spécialiste de
géopolitique et de philosophie politique